في منطقه ال بو كمال محمد الجزائري من ريف
حلب من ريف حلب الشمالي اذا محمد الجزائري
معنا اطلعنا عن المعطيات على
الارض حتى الان المعطيات الموجوده هي ان
طيران مجهول استهدف عده مواقع في محيط
منطقه البوكمال بالاضافه الى مواقع جنوب
منطقه مدينه الميادين التي هي تعتبر شرق
مدينه دير الزور وهذه المنطقه التي تتواجد
فيها قوات مدعومه من قبل ايران هذه
الغارات استهدفت عده مواقع ليست موقع او
موقعين استهدفت عده مواقع هذه الغارات
بالاضافه الى ان المصادر المحليه قالت ان
هناك سماع سماع سيارات الاسعاف تتوجه الى
المنطقه وتنقل لربما انها تنقل مصابين او
قتلى من هذه من جراء هذه الغارات وهذه
المنطقه تعتبر المنطقه الاستراتيجيه
بالنسبه الى القوات المدعومه من قبل ايران
لكونها على الحدود السوريه العراقيه والتي
تعتبر تؤمن دخول
واللوجستيات والقوات والعناصر المدعومه من
قبل ايران من الحدود العراقيه هذه الغارات
حتى الان لم يتبين هويه الطيران الذي
استهدفها والمواقع وما وما نتج عنها
بالتحديد حتى الان